ensemble ensemble une volonté commune
pour un nouvel ensemble territorial
coignières et maurepas partagent déjà un
même code postal de nombreux projets
intercommunaux archives déchetterie
police municipale un centre aquatique et
bientôt une nouvelle identité
il faut qu'on aille justement dans cette
formidable aventure qui est historique
pour nos habitants et audacieuse en
termes de qualité de service public le
service public on va proposer à nos
habitants c'est à dire de toujours faire
mieux avec nos moyens
une décision partie motivée par la
baisse des dotations de l'état ne
souhaitant pas augmenter les impôts les
maires de coignières et maurepas ont
décidé de s'unir
un mariage qui devrait intervenir le 1er
janvier 2019
depuis 2010 la loi permet en effet aux
communes de regrouper leurs
administrations respectives
actuellement en france il existe cinq
cent cinquante sept communes nouvelles
un nouveau mode de fonctionnement qui
seraient exposés à la population dans
les prochaines semaines il y aura besoin
d'information d'écouté de compréhension
aussi de la population de nos
administrés et donc c'est une phase
d'ici à la fin de l'année et je dirais
même à l'automne d'ici à l'automne c'est
une phase très très importante
on ne fait pas pour nous on le fait pour
les habitants pour garantir une qualité
de service public qui est tant attendu
par nos populations
un projet d'avenir qui donnera lieu à de
nombreux changements un seul maire mais
aussi un nouveau nom pour cette commune
nouvelle
nous aurons besoin d'une votation besoin
de l'avis de la population et il faudra
conserver également l'esprit mort passe
bien mais aussi l'esprit coignières dans
le dans le dans le nom de cette nouvelle
commune et ce sera déterminée d'ici
d'ici quelques mois rue dès cette
semaine les habitants de maurepas et
coignières recevront une lettre
explicative sur cette ambition commune